Speaker 1: Well, the battle against the
coronavirus is not going to be ending
anytime soon, if you've been following
the numbers, you know that not only are
the numbers in the United States in general really
not looking good disproportionately so, of course,
among the unvaccinated. But we also have some
states that are at their pandemic peaks now,
their pandemic peaks now in terms of daily cases,
they are in pandemic peaks now in terms of total
hospitalizations. And the death numbers are
going very much in the wrong direction. Again,
mostly unvaccinated people. But there is this
question of what about the vaccinated? Because
there is no question that we are seeing
breakthrough cases, which are mostly mild,
but we're seeing breakthrough hospitalizations
as well, although relatively fewer in number,
and we're seeing breakthrough deaths as
well. And there is early data from Israel
showing that it starts to seem it seems as
though it starts maybe around five, six months.
And then there's a noticeable drop off at the
eight, eight, eight month mark that there is
declining efficacy in these vaccines. And so the
question of a third booster dose has been raised
over the last several weeks and months. And we
now have heard from the CDC, the U.S. will begin
wide distribution of covid booster shots next
month, saying vaccine protection wanes over
time. There's a good write up about this on CNBC.
And these are third doses, third doses for people
who have already had two doses of Moderna or
two doses of Fizer like I and many of you in
the audience have as well. The article writes, The
US will start widely distributing covid booster
shots next month as new data shows vaccine
protection wanes over time. Top U.S. health
officials announced Wednesday it is now, quote,
very clear that immunity starts to fall after
the initial two doses. And with the dominance
of the Delta variant, quote, We are starting to
see evidence of reduced protection against mild
and moderate disease, according to the statement
signed by CDC director Rochelle Walensky.
Let's go now to Rochelle Walensky speaking
yesterday and listen to what she had to say
Speaker 2: through the end of July and early
August. Three points are now very clear. First,
vaccine induced protection against sars-cov-2
infection begins to decrease over time.
Speaker 1: Now important, she's talking
there about infection. Now, next, she
will talk about the other elements.
Speaker 2: Second, vaccine effectiveness
against severe disease, hospitalization and
death remains relatively high. Yes. And
third, vaccine effectiveness is generally
decreased against the Delta variant. So let's
jump into the data on this slide. You will see
two studies, one from New York and one an analysis
of data from the Mayo Clinic from May 3rd through
July. Twenty fifth, New York examined covid-19
tests and linked them to individuals vaccination
status based on the state's vaccine records. This
is huge. This allowed New York to study vaccine
effectiveness against infection over time for more
than 10 million New Yorkers of all ages. Vaccine
effectiveness in May, during early during the
vaccine rollout in the state was 92 percent in the
later months. Further from vaccination, vaccine
effectiveness declined to 80 percent. These data
will be published in the MMW are today. The Mayo
Clinic analysis looked at vaccine effectiveness
for both the Pfizer and Majano vaccines.
Speaker 1: OK, so what is the point here?
The point here is over time, efficacy wanes. And
there's really two aspects to this. And this is
we don't know the answer to this, but this
is a really important thing to understand.
The efficacy in the real world is in part waning
because the virus variant that is dominant now
is not the one that the vaccine was developed
against. This is different than vaccine efficacy
goes down against the live variant, the original
variant against which the vaccines were designed.
It may or it may not, but we don't yet have
reason to believe that. And so this may well
become like a flu shot type situation where I'm
scheduled to get my flu shot in a few days myself.
The flu shot I will get in a few days is based
on what was believed to be the dominant strain
at the time that this year's flu shot started
to be developed. I don't know if it's six or
eight months ago. And depending on how well
that matches what's actually out there in
this upcoming flu season, I will have a lower
or higher degree of protection. And similarly,
when we talk about the covid-19 vaccine, the
same same question applies, which is how?
How. How closely does the variant that is
dominant match what the vaccines were designed
for? So this is this is where we are going. And
the guidance, as far as we understand it now,
is going to be starting eight months after your
second dose of the Fizer or Moderna vaccine.
For me, I received my second dose February 26th
so I would become eligible on October 26th. And
if that's the case and the vaccine is available, I
will go and get a third shot because I want to not
only protect myself, but protect people around
me. There are, of course, people who have not
gotten any vaccine and don't plan to who are
going to take this as an opportunity to say,
now, I'm definitely not getting the vaccine,
even though they already definitely weren't
getting the vaccine, because they
will say this is just part of the plot
to get us more and more and more doses forever.
Well, when something becomes endemic like flu,
that's the way it will sometimes work and that's
the way it does work with flu. So, of course,
people who want to see a conspiracy will see one
anywhere they want. They will see it in evidence
and they will see it in the absence of evidence.
And these are not really good faith actors that
we can deal with in any serious way. But this is
where we are right now and many people are feeling
and understandably so. Will this ever end like
is this ever going to go away? And the answer is,
it may not ever go away as an endemic thing
that is just circulating with peaks and valleys,
sort of like flu. But if we get enough people
vaccinated and eventually it seems likely
we would have a reformulated vaccine tailored to
maybe the Delta variant, maybe to a variant that
is still sometime in the future, or we can get
it under control from the standpoint of it being
a pandemic. But certainly, you know, things like
masks on planes have been extended until January,
at minimum until January. We are starting to see
vaccine requirements increasingly in different
cities and states to go to restaurants, to go
to indoor venues. This this stuff is not going
to end anytime soon. And of course, part
of the reason is a whole bunch of people
still are not interested in getting
vaccinated. At least one doctor and
I'm going to talk about this next, is saying
he will no longer treat unvaccinated patients.